sin duda a día extraordinario y bien
dramático en la política británica desde
hace 24 horas 36 ministros senior del
gabinete de boris johnson entre ellos
además vice ministros y altos
funcionarios han renunciado a su cargo
esperando que el primer ministro haga lo
mismo en este momento una comisión de
ministros integrada además por quien
acaba de ser nombrado ministro de
finanzas de economía nadie sabe guau y
se encuentran dentro del distrito
esperando a que el primer ministro
regrese después de comparecer en una
comisión del parlamento para decirle que
su tiempo ha llegado que debe irse
entonces a partir de ese momento la
verdad es que no hay certeza de que va a
pasar porque este es un día bien
extraordinario como les digo así que no
sabemos si boris johnson después de
escuchar a sus propios ministros
diciéndole es hora de que se vaya es
hora de que un paso al costado renuncie
esta noche o lo haga en las próximas
horas pero el consenso por lo que hemos
escuchado a lo largo del día y por
rápido que se ha desenvuelto este
episodio el consenso es que boris
johnson su tiempo por lo menos siempre
en downing street ha llegado a su final
así que es una jornada bien bien
dramática dramática y larga no a la
espera entonces de la decisión que
tomará el primer mes o si seguirá
adelante como él ha dicho o si realmente
hacerle caso a los ministros reflexionar
yo denunciar pero también lo hice el
comité conservador de 1922 habría
decidido no cambiar estas reglas para
permitir un segundo voto de confianza
contra boris johnson en cambio va a
celebrar elecciones el lunes para elegir
un nuevo ejecutivo qué consecuencias va
a tener esta decisión además se suma una
raya más al tigre como dicen
sin duda yo creo que mucho de esta
decisión que ha sido adoptada en los
últimos minutos tiene que ver con darle
la oportunidad del primer ministro de
renunciar de irse sin que sea despedido
de una u otra manera por los integrantes
de su partido este comité en 1922 es
bien poderoso porque decide el futuro
del primer ministro como mencionas las
elecciones serían el lunes y
posiblemente el martes y boris johnson
no ha renunciado de aquí a esa fecha
entonces podría convocarse a una nueva
moción de confianza para que los
diputados del partido voten y se decida
si entonces boris johnson que es lo más
probable debe irse pero el jefe de este
partido de este comité en 1922 es bien
poderoso porque puede decirle al primer
ministro su tiempo ha llegado a los
diputados de su partido ya no confían en
usted así que las próximas 24 o 48 horas
en este país serán definitivas ahora sí
para el futuro de boris johnson